yeah hello welcome to our show yep sorry
for the late start I had some issues
with them someone with the webcam
lighting setup I still look kind of deer
than the in the video I think I don't
really know what happened it looked
actually worse before I did the tweaking
and it still doesn't look good I look
kind of unhealthy I don't know let's um
let's get let's get going over some
games um here we go trying for some five
minute games so yeah yeah I don't look
don't look tent I just look weird I I
don't really know what happened I think
I have to probably change the the lights
or something it's really weird I don't
know what it is okay I've requested a
five minute game but I didn't get one
yet so have to be a bit patient here to
get this started gain started okay MN o
is the opponent and I've got some nice
rating build up to screw up so let's see
what happens playing a reti opening go
get a reverse gruene photo of this guy
is a very fast player Bishop to e7 okay
okay let's put some and pressure there
on the center wow that is a line and
recently this has become a little bit
more respectable in former times their
generous greenford was basically
believed in complete nonsense but it
seems that
black is currently thinking this is
actually something playable yeah maybe
so putting some pressure on d5 my night
will come to d4 this is my idea it's
certainly not a bad position for white
but yeah the question here by Nicholas
Santiago Freda was the German junior
championships in willing and successful
um yeah I think I'm pretty happy with
them with the event it was a it's a very
nice tournament the German juniors
imagine six seven hundred kids playing
in one hole it's pretty pretty nice um
yeah I got to work with three of the
participants and check all of them they
were seeded in the lower half of them of
their respective age group so and nobody
of the three was really am in contention
to win so um you have to be quite
realistic what they could do and they
all performed according to the rating so
it wasn't it wasn't some spectacular
performance but it was quite okay for me
it was a very interesting experience
because I also I don't have much of
experience to work with junior players
so it was was nice to do okay what am I
doing here I tried to go to d2 and and
go from there
yeah what to do here at five hmm if I go
no okay 94 this f3 yeah it's kind of
funny as you said arbiter he's eating my
piece I think there were very little
like protests and things like that I
think the kids some they really they
behave too very M very okay i think the
the most problematic actually the UM the
parents sometimes
so what to do here for maybe I wasn't
sure about this before but now I would
go we go for it oh I think what
Sebastian is saying is not then they
they know the rules very well I mean
it'sit's the national championships
after all but it's it's definitely not
easy sometimes with the more complicated
stuff like a draw bye-bye three forward
repetition or losing on time things like
that are kind of critical in that level
okay um I probably didn't play that too
well 93 here looks very very problematic
and I cannot move the bishop I can go to
age three yeah I will go there but I
don't like it yeah of course I'm
blundering a full piece in this game
great stuff didn't see that one coming
and he can he can rescue the night
unfortunately by AG one to f3
ya know g1 is a very simple win I don't
know what he's doing here I mean other
things also win but not g 1 2 or 3 is
very simple yes very simple
I still don't like to give up maybe I
canon 95 is a very cheap cheap idea but
a check can still try yeah the exchange
down also was completely lost so Jack
yeah I can actually just resign this
game it's kind of pointless play resides
it's pretty up pretty bad I mean this
position is just should you should never
lose it but okay I managed so a new game
need to get into stride iam I played a
couple of games earlier today and it was
very ok so I don't know a very simple
line against the gruene felt even if it
doesn't give while an edge jam Bishop g5
is not a bad line something you can
definitely try I like to play Bishop f4
which is kind of middle-of-the-road
theoretical it's not a super heavy
theory but still something be 6a this is
getting more and more popular Queenie
seventh and I never looked at this which
is a problem which is a mistake I should
have looked at that
okay I just try to develop quickly
Bishop t2 against the gruene fell is
also a good idea yeah check see take
seat XD 5 and see takes d5 95 bishop d2
yeah interesting line here that black is
playing it seems like it's getting very
decent play against by d5 pawn should g5
I guess I guess so okay I've got a very
nice development here this is not too
bad
rook e1 I wonder ever have something
more aggressive available here than some
standard continuation d6 is interesting
here this pollution tags and Bishop
takes age 64 Queen g6 mmm that might
work let's go for it I haven't haven't
completely calculated this though and
rookie one was my idea first this and
use the tempo mi Bishop this diagonal is
open now Bishop age 6 here check check
check this just work the question is
Bishop g7 and then g5 maybe maybe coming
hmm then I have 95 for what it's worth
but I'm not quite sure that it actually
does just do anything hmm
we should be aged 65 and it probably
works it probably works for black
amazing t5 right five that sucks it
really sucks d5 Queen f5 maybe I can
when I playing this now even though I
probably it doesn't work ok yes to go d
5m this is the only move I don't see a
winning continuation after that though
well Queen f5 takes Queen G 59 th seems
to just about hold
Bishop g7 then Queen f5 the id-5 was
there when you move em he couldn't take
and queen age 61 Judith Retta it was the
only move they looked is six at the end
of that line Bishop takes Queen g6
checking edge at Queen Elsa crew k9h 756
and white wins root is six at the end
wins in that line but now I think he
probably can take something and win can
even take the bishop on age 6
now this is actually the main issue they
can take the bishop on age 6 he didn't
do it is that also working it would be
it would be kind of amazing between 25
he goes 24 what Ed's possible
Queen g-form so defense I still have
some stuff hanging so this is the thing
24 probably defense Queens you for hmm I
don't see move after 3g Foreman ok
didn't do it time Barney what now ok
let's play a quick move and hope it
works I only have one minute left hmm I
should have seen this off oh my god i'm
playing badly running into Knight f6 are
come on I'm really gifting away all
those games here against pretty awful
play actually ah god what is this Emma
look down yeah for not much and awful
just awful
hmm yeah of course you can resign you
but I don't like to still try for some
some cheap tricks you have six days work
and unfortunately neither three-year
even works check okay play so fantastic
start dropping 50 points until it's very
very stupid games so let's see if I can
do here against I am Stefan off it
Sicilian with black yeah I can do that
yeah I get some wacky line here
never see this opening here very strange
stuff so weird mix of a rillo pass with
whatever any chance you can play the
bird no just no chance I really have no
I mean I'm not playing well the first
games and I'm not playing some crab
opening where I'm worse after a couple
of wolves I won't sorry guys I want to
score some points in there was a
question any plans for my channel as
there were only blitz games recently I
had plans to do things but they didn't
work out as simply didn't have enough
time I mean I don't like I couldn't do
it simply wanted to do something on my
league games actually because I had a
couple of interesting ones in the in the
Bundesliga but didn't didn't find the
time to do it and ok let's let's open up
this as much as possible c5 opens up the
diagonal of the bishop and he cannot
take now sv5 singing 9525 is a maid
threat so all this looks good let's see
what he what the answers
he d centralizes the night ok I can take
this though right so what's going on
here i can play night to be for now yeah
there's the suggestion of some
non-alcoholic beer to get things going
um I don't have any any of those
available i want to cut down on them but
i definitely drink too much of those so
what now yeah probably this one yeah and
I'm a pawn up I have the better central
control and I have got the bishop pair
it looks like i should win and i
probably would screw it up but ok we'll
see what happens currently I'm
threatening Bishop b3 which is pretty
good not that easy actually to fight
yeah drinking too much non-alcoholic
beer could be worse then you're probably
right it could be worse but it's so
pretty you know I think it's got some
some decent develop sugar that I want to
cut down on right to d3 is my idea here
maybe has to actually take that night
nope 93 this Bishop c7 or what's the
deal don't understand that moment with
the Queen has to go back now right all
the way or is there something good this
one ok I've got d 3 or this one and
night go into a 6 ok
it's just kicking away the f3 enter I
Greenfeld yeah that's a good line of
course you have to be ready to play very
sharp positions though so don't complain
if you get something that you don't
understand it can easily happen that you
have a completely completely wacky
position maybe actually with the bishop
prevent any Knight b6 stuff
it's still not easy it's still not easy
who is six maybe someone recommended
where was able to play someone said
non-alcoholic vodka don't tell me this
actually exists it sounds pretty weird
okay Bishop g5 maybe or Bishop to e7
yeah this is probably okay attacking the
night
how many beers what is this what's nice
is not blundering a piece it is
blundering a piece like reason yes
getting on the scoreboard and how many
beers does it take for me to play the
poor guy yes key variation of the night
off oh my probably a lot yeah just
entirely not my kind of game when it's
so um so I'll try complicated that I
don't understand anything so gain it's
nice I got a point in now let's see what
I can do against Matt p with my with a
cup of variation your English yes
somehow people get good positions
against me with it this 95 idea is
really annoying
should bake trees seems okay though and
let's do this
oh this is interesting I don't think
this this is particularly grateful wide
ever leave now I think his bishop looks
like in a problem it's a little problem
yeah I know I look a little bit strange
today it's not it's not actually me it's
the camera boy let's say the lighting I
don't really know what happened it's a
bit a bit bit strange I know you know
the birds opening what I just said about
the goods opening it is not that bad
it's just that I really see no point in
playing this with air for white
basically gives up any hope for an
advantage immediately but ok you can you
can play it it's not like it's it's
terrible and there's a question about
the right ear opening why black gives up
the bishop and a certain line with
Bishop g4 tower three um yeah this
doesn't have a very clear cut cut answer
actually and it depends a bit on the
specific variation sometimes black does
that because he wants to make sure that
there's no 95 hitting the bishop on g4
the question was about something like
Knight f3 I g5g three Bishop g4 oh this
is bad I I basically didn't pay any
attention here I don't want him to be
able to take this now the position is
equal well before I was slightly better
ya know it's equal ok I don't offer
material here mm-hmm whatever not sure
if this was a wise decision check for
him to decline the drawer check and see
getting to my porn CEO okay can go back
but I can jump into c3 and to try to
take stuff getting interesting check I
should have thought about this for a
moment i mean ii ii or can also teach g6
this one maybe oh now we'll get this
pawn
check what to do here um be 54 9485 i
guess and night c 2 is coming up well
that's winning right what is he doing
here I can just take it what am I doing
here aah aah i didn't calculate that at
all I just hope it works what what am I
doing here yeah what the heck could have
just play night situ and I take before I
simply didn't see that it can take to
the pawn my god
night see for texts Enki for King c8 can
you through King be sound from the draw
check and I'm just in time I'm just in
time here 85 and probably wins go a lot
Kings the three can be five just win
king d 303 also wins Oh
check
this reason seems oh my god for i simply
I'm I totally forgot that he can take it
and I still think it's the draw it is a
draw Jeff King III is drawing a for
Casey true yeah I cannot win him he's
just about in time I'm sorry and this
one and it's a draw it was ever so
utterly idiotic I can just play King c7
here and it is over yeah I just win this
born I just fit this Bob Knepper game
its own style next one against the moss
I just call it Moss because I cannot
pronounce that he usually plays this
snake Benoni which is not particularly
great but let's do something else that's
funny it's a Bishop e7 benoni okay maybe
rook e8 Bishop of a g6 at the end Black
will be a tempo down or so on and
regular benoni efore or c5 I yeah I mean
I can go one year for maybe next game or
one of the next games
okay so he likes to put up this blockade
yeah before was my idea not sure that it
does work though probably not ok I'm
going to trade this yeah this is this is
translated as the brain pecker if i'm
not wrong brain picker or something like
that but i cannot pronounce it so so
black no s block heated this pawn nicely
my idea is to play with before I'm sure
that I can get the zendo
I'm not going to play the elephant
gambit this is really not a good idea
okay I need to make this night mobile I
can get to trade nights this position
isn't so bad like this this is quite
okay see porn more weakness you get to
see three that would be kind of nice and
then bring the looks around I mean I
probably don't win the pawn it's very
difficult to do so oh he wants to trade
one interesting since like a man we
don't unlucky spot down oh how do i how
to do that I can take with the rook and
go on to seventh rank it's definitely
good for for check for white yeah okay
let's get on the seven I can take this
and take the youporn to probably wins
but I can go here as well
you
for coming hmm what's the way to get
this purse going quickly I wonder have
f4 is an option okay don't have that
much time check yeah I don't think rooks
III is a big deal as my pawns is just
too strong and T I'm threatening if I've
check so Brooks III won't work at all
this is what I had seen and I think I'm
threatening me five now okay so maybe
just back and then support him support
the pawns from the back now from behind
I mean yeah probably should look
hmm maybe not okay three is very lame
but maybe okay Quincy five key oh I
could see five King c5 just King c3 and
try to just improve a bit kinky three
next and then approve the rook I mean
it's too connected passes after all okay
yeah just check and go kinky for right
oh it's that bad King you for AI don't
think it can be bad the two point should
be too strong check
hmm oopsie for storage still an issue
but I think I can push all the way home
check it you seven it's got Ricky eight
done
Lucas III doesn't work right you can't
i'm morning traitors hmm check check
this should window come on that's its
winning check check check check check
check check mate wow wow tough i don't
really know it was an interesting ending
yeah okay i don't analyze it showed too
much but I want to have a new game and
I'm kind of coming back here from a bad
start okay I didn't really follow the
check the chat that much because you
know I had to work hard him one if for
or c5 let's see gain started ok so
that's that's a Sicilian right against
international master light like Martin
songs under so pretty good i am so to 24
70 or something as a score this is quite
is writing so we get him regardless is
free so not for shortly so i try to play
sharp of it people don't play along this
line i just think this is so great
actually
this is a line that I analyzed a little
bit with one of the kids in the injured
German juniors and we said we concluded
that white can play this line but it
isn't particularly scary his name is
Suzanne de no I never met him a question
in the chat try to get this Bishop
quickly check
yeah so why does it pawn up but I've got
two bishops and a good structure yam so
where to put it to e5 or to f6 think I
go here I've got compensation for the
porn i think but it's it's not easy to
play I don't know a six the bishop
doesn't have many squares might take
only five okay I go asics a bit unsure
about this it might be not so great for
my structure
yeah a question is how to get the porn
back mmhmm yeah the thing that actually
concerns me most is that my pawn see our
own light squares and they might be
attacked by this bishop so this is a bit
of a cause for concern did I have Bishop
g4 oh my god oh my god it's been a long
day but still Bishop chief okay okay
great stuff so that would have been
pretty nice composition for the pawn
that if I just could have won the house
cool
okay so what about this going back here
okay my idea is rook c8 now getting the
pawn back that way yeah sometimes the
chat would actually really yeah it would
be nice to get let's get some of those
remarks in time ok so I'm doing it
playing it simple now him yeah yeah I'm
very okay but not sure I've had
something better but I'm just okay i'm
getting stuff back yeah you need that
beer maybe known that that non-alcoholic
beer usually helped I gave it my
position is fine yeah I think check
taking here and now he's 66 maybe look
um we'll get one
you know I can take this one he
definitely wants to play on the seventh
but sure how much it does
maybe I shouldn't have played this song
so quickly here if I go e6 what is the
deal who gave one or something and don't
know but should be four would be almost
a self-made yeah here I can take those
two pawns and play rogue f8 at the end I
was thinking or the chick throat him
chance is ok now this chick but it's
useful to take you to write so let's do
this check ok getting this one and it's
tough for him to keep the kingside so
probably I will take the rest of the
pawns yep I'll take the rest of the
points two points up should be
relatively easily winning
kh5 yes mmm gee if I walked you three
wins stuff check and now how to do this
for movie 6j I just need a rope trade
here check know what that was stupid I
mean okay it doesn't really check it
much check okay so this is a simple win
oh ok I'm on a tough game I don't think
that this line is too scary g6 is a line
that we looked at at this tournament for
like to play for a win against you three
it's a pretty good recommendation I
think if you want to unbalance the game
just six is kind of kind of cool okay
let's go for a new game so I did
actually lose the first tool started
then got a string of wins and chest
coach for you ok that's a good handle
again that bloody line ok I just want
something else mom Jack
as a question chess in public places
recommendations or suggestions where to
find that hmm not quite sure I mean
obviously New York yeah but there will
be probably lots more when I was playing
in the mid-90s roughly 20 years ago it
was fantastic chess cafe in Berlin which
we frequented quite a lot ok that's a
nice pollution ok so black is happy with
playing this somewhat passive looking
position let's see how this unfolds I'm
trying to keep all the pieces on the
board and try to get some long-term
pressure here rook to divorce may be
coming and she falls probably and far
too far too crude so yeah we have the
rook trade here that's basically not
avoidable
not sure if I played this in the right
move order now we'll see what happens so
have a hmm why does he allow this Queen
trade would be cool Bishop c7 ideas
naive on trade the Queen would be quite
accommodating preparing a lucrative one
a bishop f6 is not a threat i guess know
how do i get roped you want a nectarine
should be on c2 and then route it to
everyone I can so what do you want just
around the corner yeah the minor piece
ending I can definitely try to pay for
win better space b6 is weaker than c4 I
think okay it seems that he's angling
for this kind of thing okay 96
especially five so this is not happening
i guess our case going back good so how
am i doing this may be here probably
should be five
my ideas 45 now ok it's defending this
Wow f5 is fighting for the e4 square
Jeff Jeff I don't know here g5 or what I
don't know how to will after that it
looks nice but it's so shut down
probably not a great idea probably have
to open up the position more tough tough
tough tough okay interesting now I can
potentially take here and then g5 and
then you fall okay this may be
interesting you cannot go to you for
maybe I'd age 5 is actually a move I
came check okay now I didn't see that
one coming simply didn't know where
Bishop is not looking great but ok I can
get III and right I can get you 3n I can
still play this position what is what is
an idea Bishop to d3 maybe and then you
form he wants to get the night to g6
here
okay that's the only way forward check
check check that's probably strong time
warning okay then kill all the win grah
i heard yeah maybe he can actually play
this position for a win justifiably
check I have little time yeah it's kind
of silly then I'm actually getting two
losers aah chak I definitely wanted to
win and I probably could have won
somehow would be kind of logical the way
the game went when I was pressing all
the way but maybe I simply had no win
let's see one I found that I hate to
lose games like that's how you press the
whole game and then you simply do do a
little bit too much to do it too much
pressing i'm pretty sure that i had ways
to win this game with such a dominating
position here I don't know tough to say
tough to same okay um one more game yes
I played I started a little bit late so
I will bow I will go for one more game
there may be defended this occasion I
tried to join here and maybe try too
hard position like this is super
one-sided champion but i guess it was ok
maybe so come on give me a game here in
the pool soon as I don't get a game gain
started a good one um ok cell 20
something I'm going for Kings Indian
yeah try it for something sharp I can
you play some boring fianchetto system
ok and going to be 3 never seen this
move yeah bishop age 3 is probably
probably not going to work here and but
still see just giving me the bishop pair
yes that's nice i like your ships give
me bishops oh ok Mike retweet maybe it's
not that well placed can you trap it
somehow i don't i don't don't quite see
how
maybe like Age 3 or something it's Reno
I can I can just take that so it's not
happening
and there was a remark in the chat about
Nigel shorts comment that chest teaching
chest will rot your brain this is what
Nigel said and I think he's got a point
in some way I don't think that teaching
on a somewhat decent level like good
club players does hurt your game the
teachers game but teaching on a very low
level like on the scholastic love this
could could hurt you i think it's a it's
just a totally different way of thinking
about shares of you um if you look at
those kind of games all the time you
simply forget about the i think if i get
who get a little bit about the finer
points of the game okay i try to get the
Queen back Queen to d7 thing is I'm
quite happy if the V file opens but I
couldn't couldn't get do that now I'm
threatening be a 6 yeah good night to
buy your sauce right sir I'll be on next
week so Bishop a 6 let's do that a taxi
for how do you cover it don't see it at
the mode and you just pushes forward
yeah I can take e5 and i think i will do
that tween it's nice on b8 looking at
all the relevant things
Bishop g6 know that really working Wow
hard to believe Bishop c4 Bishop g6 hmm
King g7 looks rather lame but I don't
have to tie it to cut it is let's just
cover it
still attacking see for him okay so it's
just going back check shouldn't be five
or something should be possible in here
for some bishop here on the the long
diagonal that would be cool don't see it
though okay let's just cover this Wow
nah come on that's not going to work so
they don't believe this and one bit oh I
didn't see that it was hanging wow I
mean it still shouldn't work but I
should have seen that ah my god
this is getting somewhat scary I just
didn't see that this was hanging
otherwise I wouldn't have said that it
shouldn't work at all this this is
dangerous bishop age five is on the
cards damn it don't know from that
position if what's just totally winning
I mean like completely winning nonsense
okay I have to go for this bloody
endgame then what is this pawn downer
great great stuff very likely going to
be a draw but it's not exactly what you
want from a position that was clearly
better
time warning check it's probably again
too ambitious yeah I'm trying to do
something that I shouldn't do not anyway
what it's just a blitz game no I'm
running in which says I'm running it too
mate we should be a check kingi five
rupees sex checkmate checkmate Oh age
for me I should have stopped one but
kick before that now below 2400 again ah
two very stupid games I mean look at
this position yeah I mean rookie six is
just not working at all I mean nothing
is work rupee six and he resigns it I
just didn't see that a cig Zhang's ok
probably build a bit too late him ok as
I hope you enjoyed the show it had some
good points up at points so um I guess
some blunders are quite entertaining ok
so i'll be back next week next monday
also i'll be on next saturday for the
similar master i'm going to post a video
north of video for that as well next
saturday at i'm not quite sure what it
is eight or nine pm and numb unknown
central european time i'll post
something separate for that ok thanks
for watching guys bye bye